Wenn ein Asteroid in absehbarer Zeit der Erde
gefährlich nahe kommen sollte, wären wir
ihm schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Denn auch wenn Forschungsteams weltweit mit
Hochdruck an Methoden tüfteln, eine solche
Bedrohung abzuwehren oder zumindest abzuschwächen,
ist noch keine davon auch nur ansatzweise
ausgereift.
Doch die Zeit spielt gegen uns und so hat
die NASA einen wirklich krassen Plan: Schon
im Herbst 2022 soll ein Asteroid mit einem
gezielten Einschlag aus seiner Bahn geworfen
werden.
WHAT?!
Alles was ihr zu dieser mega spektakulären
Mission wissen müsst, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
Clixoom Science & Fiction, herzlich willkommen!
Die aktuelle Situation ist folgende: Wenn
wir mit Teleskopen Objekte am Himmel ausmachen
würden, die sich auf Kollisionskurs mit der
Erde befinden, hätten wir kaum eine Chance,
dieses tödliche Schicksal noch abzuwenden.
Konkrete Abwehrmaßnahmen sind bisher nämlich
noch Mangelware.
Doch genau das soll sich jetzt ändern.
DART steht für “Double Asteroid Redirection
Test” und die NASA will mit diesem Manöver
schon im Oktober 2022 ein spektakuläres und
neuartiges Asteroidenabwehr-Verfahren testen.
Das Ziel wird der erdnahe Doppelasteroid 65803
sein.
Er wurde 1996 entdeckt und wenig später fiel
dann auch auf, dass es sich bei dem Objekt
um einen Doppelkörper handelt.
Deswegen sein Name “Didymos”; die griechische
Bezeichnung für “Zwilling”.
Der größere Brocken von beiden hat einen
Durchmesser von 800 Metern; der Kleinere einen
Durchmesser von etwa 150 Metern.
Letzterer wird manchmal auch als “Didymoon”
bezeichnet.
Er umkreist den größeren Didymos-Körper
in einer Entfernung von 1,1 Kilometern und
braucht für eine Umrundung rund 11,9 Stunden.
Und um das direkt einmal klarzustellen: Das
Zielobjekt ist aktuell keine Bedrohung für
unsere Erde.
Das NASA-Manöver dient lediglich dazu, uns
für den Ernstfall vorzubereiten.
Die Flugbahn-Änderung von “Didymoon”
soll durch die 500 Kilogramm schwere Raumsonde
DART ausgelöst werden, die dem NASA-Plan
zufolge am 7.
Oktober 2022 mit sechs Kilometern pro Sekunde
auf den Asteroiden treffen soll.
An Bord hat sie ein Navigationssystem und
eine Bordkamera, damit sie ihr Ziel auf jeden
Fall nicht verfehlt.
Der Aufprall würde nach den Berechnungen
der NASA eine Veränderung der Bahngeschwindigkeit
von “Didymoon” um etwa 0,4 Millimetern
pro Sekunde bewirken.
Auch, wenn das zunächst nach einer minimalen
Veränderung klingt, wäre solch eine Neuausrichtung
groß genug, um sie mit Teleskopen von der
Erde aus zu messen.
Dieses Manöver würde zeigen, ob wir mit
solch einer Mission tatsächlich auch einen
Asteroiden, der sich auf Kollisionskurs mit
der Erde befindet, erfolgreich umzulenken
könnten.
Denn fest steht: Schon eine kleine Flugbahnänderung
eines Asteroiden könnte das Fortbestehen
der Erde sicherstellen.
Elf Millionen Kilometer wird das Asteroiden-Zwillingssystem
zum Zeitpunkt des Aufpralls von DART von der
Erde entfernt sein.
Damit die Sonde, die übrigens 12,5 Meter
mal 2,4 Meter groß ist, “Didymoon” pünktlich
erreichen kann, müsste der Raketenstart im
Zeitrahmen zwischen Dezember 2020 und Mai
2021 gelingen.
Dazu Lindley Johnson von der NASA: „DART
wäre die erste Mission der NASA, welche die
so genannte Kinetic Impactor Technique demonstriert,
einen Asteroiden mit einem gezielten Einschlag
von seiner Umlaufbahn zu schieben, um sich
gegen einen möglichen zukünftigen Asteroideneinschlag
zu verteidigen”.
Eine echte Premiere also, denn bei DART geht
es nicht wie bei bisherigen Missionen darum,
wissenschaftliche Daten zu den Asteroiden
zu sammeln. wie bei den beiden Asteroiden-Besuche
der NASA-Raumsonde “Osiris Rex” und der
japanischen Asteroiden-Mission “Hayabusa2”
- wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Stattdessen handelt es sich bei der “DART-Mission”
sage und schreibe um die erste planetare Verteidigungs-Mission
überhaupt.
Und so werden nicht nur Boden-Teleskope eingesetzt,
um den Aufprall und dessen Folgen genau zu
beobachten.
Auch die Europäische Weltraumorganisation
ESA ist mit am Start.
Auch sie plant, eine Raumsonde zu Didymos
zu schicken.
“Hera” soll allerdings erst 2023 starten
und DART folgen.
Dann könnte sie wichtige Daten zu dem Didymos-Asteroiden
sammeln.
Die ESA möchte zudem einen Nanosatelliten
auf “Didymoon” aufsetzen lassen, der den
von DART erzeugten Krater genau vermessen
soll.
Der Lander “Juventas” ist 12 kg schwer
und etwa so groß wie ein Schuhkarton.
Er soll zusammen mit “Hera” zu dem Asteroiden
fliegen und zudem auch mit Radarwellen das
Innere von “Didymoon” analysieren.
Denn auch die innere Struktur und die Oberflächen-Beschaffenheit
eines Himmelskörpers entscheiden maßgeblich
darüber, wie sich dieser beim Aufprall eines
Objektes verhält.
Genau deswegen sind auch diese Erkenntnisse
enorm wichtig, um die neue Technologie zur
Abwehr von Asteroiden zu perfektionieren.
Wir haben bei Clixoom Science & Fiction schon
über verschiedene Techniken zur Asteroidenabwehr
berichtet.
Maßgeblich an der Entwicklung beteiligt ist
die NASA-Behörde namens “Planetary Defense
Coordination Office”, die erst 2016 gegründet
wurde.
Noch im Sommer 2018 hatte die NASA ein ausführliches
Strategiepapier zur Asteroiden-Abwehr vorgelegt:
Demnach müssen dringend Möglichkeiten entwickelt
werden, mit denen die Flugbahn von Gesteinsbrocken
beeinflusst werden kann.
Auch hier betont die NASA noch einmal, dass
die Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen Einschlag
zwar gering ist, doch die Folgen umso katastrophaler.
Bis 2020 sollen alle erdnahen Asteroiden,
die größer sind als 140 Meter, zuverlässig
entdeckt werden.
Experten und Expertinnen plädieren immer
wieder für eine bessere weltweite Zusammenarbeit
und den Aufbau eines koordinierten Frühwarnsystems.
Denn wir alle wissen, was bei einem Asteroideneinschlag
auf der Erde passieren könnte - Hollywood-Filme
und Serien dazu gibt es genug.
Fliegende Trümmer, Tsunami-Wellen und schlimme
Erdbeben etwa könnten einen Großteil des
Lebens auf der Erde auslöschen.
Asteroiden einfach erklärt Klickt auf dieses
Video, schaut es an und abonniert Raumzeit
Vlog der Zukunft.
Es lohnt sich.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!